hey guys it is Wednesday I'm just I'm
Dan and Dan's gonna do the burp up for
you today I'm not a robot you all is a
robot I'm everything on a robot I'm 100%
human what I'm definitely a human there
is no dance my people don't dance
yesterday we told you what games you can
get as part of your xbox live
subscription in August now it seems only
fair that we let you know what
PlayStation Plus games you can pick up
with your subscription in August for the
eighth month of 2017 ps4 players can
think their time into the open world
destruction of Just Cause 3 as well as
the Assassin's Creed freedom cry freedom
cry is the standalone spin-off to
Assassin's Creed Black Flag in which you
play as Adewale as slave turned assassin
on ps3 you can grab snake ball and super
motherlode while your dusty Vita might
get a workout this month with level 22
and the incredibly addictive down well
which is also available on ps4 buy
across buy more evidence that August is
indeed the best month of the year for
those of you like crash band 2010 on our
news comments yesterday who is hoping
the same school would also arrive on ps4
we've got good news for you it is in
fact coming to ps4 sure is it's coming
to ps4 and Xbox one on November 17 the
console versions will include the base
game plus many of the content add-ons
the sims 4 receive on PCs according to
AAA the publisher added that the game
will be supported with periodic updates
and extra content releases if you
speculated that the sims 4 would
probably be the perfect game for a bunch
of pre-order loop damn it you're right
those who buy in advance will get their
hands on the perfect patio stuff pack
which introduces outdoor decor and hot
tubs if you want to heat things up a bit
sure but in The Sims 4 you can woohoo in
a bush so you probably weren't short of
places it's work
have you never played the student you
can get three days of early access if
you preorder the deluxe party Edition
which comes with the aforementioned pack
and stuff like a flaming tiki bar crazy
costumes animal hats and other things
you probably need as you'd expect EA
access subscribers on Xbox one will be
able to play a week early the destiny to
beta wrapped up earlier this week and
Bungie has already started responding to
a bunch of feedback for example one
particularly difficult area in the game
which
that difficult has already been
addressed and apparently will be easier
in the main games speaking on the Nemec
versus saying podcast game director Luke
Smith addressed a question about the
difficult section in the homecoming
mission wherein players have to navigate
to spinning turbines that insta-kill if
touched it turns out he had no idea
there was two spinning arms in the beta
as Bungie had already removed one of
them saying that's a great example of
something that we implemented we found
it to be too challenging especially for
that opening sequence of the game and in
the shipping game we removed it this
aligns with previous Bungie statements
that the code for the beta was months
old
and doesn't represent many of the
changes Bungie have already made
internally such as increasing the
availability of heavy weapon ammo
elsewhere in the interview Smith noted
that a lot of the key elements were
being kept secret including the core
gameplay loop and progression destiny 2
is out on September 6 on ps4 and Xbox
one with the PC version following on
October 24 if you pre-order you'll get
your hands on the new cold hot exotic
trace rifle which is a new type of
weapon in destiny - that's everything we
have for you today do enjoy the rest of
your Wednesday and we'll see you guys
tomorrow